وامن ومشرف. بسبب الفساد احكام
بالسجن لثلاثة وثلاثين عاما على
الشمالية باستقبال العام الجديد
بالرقص والالعاب النارية. نعم.
وذلك بعد ان ختم كيم العام
الماضي بثلاثة صواريخ باليستية
كوريا الجنوبية. الجميع في حالة
هلع والسكان يفرون الى الملاجئ
المقابل. هناك من يستعد للحرب في
المنطقة حيث كشفت اليابان عن
الفين وثلاثة وعشرين. هيه مهلا
ما هذا الجسم المضيء في سماء
وثلاثين لمواجهة الخطر الصيني
وتهديدات كيم جونج. كيم يستفتح
شيء وليست الخيار الوحيد
للصينيين. هنا وفي تحول مفاجئ في
العام الجديد قائلا ان الناس على
جانبي مضيق تايوان اعضاء في
السياسة عرضت رئيسة تايوان ساي
انغوين على الصين تقديم المساعدة
ثلاثمائة وثلاثين مليون دولار
جراء العقوبات الغربية المشددة
يأمر بتطوير الصواريخ
الباليستية. فهل هو عام الحرب
يا سادة وبوتين يأمر بتكثيف
وتطوير صناعة الاسلحة. وكيم جونغ
اول ايام العام الجديد للاحتفال
على الطريقة الخاصة بكيم جونج.
قبل اقل من اربع وعشرين ساعة من
هذا الاطلاق. ليحتفل شعب كوريا
البحر باتجاه شبه الجزيرة
الكورية في الساعات الاولى من
اعفاء الجنود وموظفي الدولة
المنتشرين في اوكرانيا من
انتاج ما يصل الى خمسين صاروخا
من شهريا وان اي هجوم روسي كبير
الشمالية كم جونج اون بتطوير
صواريخ باليستية عابرة للقارات
بقذائف الهاون والمدفعية. وبعد
القصف العني الذي تعرضت له
الجديد بينما اعلنت اوكرانيا ان
القوات الروسية تواصل قصف خرسون
فضلا عن انتاج كميات ضخمة من
الاسلحة النووية التكتيكية. فما
الصواريخ الدفاعية الامريكية لا
تركز على روسيا او الصين بل على
موقفها تجاه تايوان. فهل حان وقت
التصافح? اليابان تتحضر لمواجهة
زعيمة ميانمار الحاصلة على جائزة
نوبل للسلام. العام الجديد بدأ
في العاصمة كييف بعد نحو ثلاثين
دقيقة من حلول رأس السنة بصوت
حظر جميع واردات الغاز الطبيعي
المسال الروسي ردا على غزو موسكو
ويبدأ الغرب بعاصفة عقوبات جديدة
على روسيا لتعلن بريطانيا بدء
بداية حرب جديدة. ها هو العام
يبدأ لتبدأ الدول بمخططاتها
الذي يحضر له الزعيم الكوري لهذا
العامي هنا البنتاجون يجيب ان
المسلمين اثر نشره صورة تعبيرية
تشير الى غسل الادوية. قال وزير
الامريكان. خلال ذلك اطلقت بيونج
يانج صاروخا باليستيا جديدا فوق
تهديد كوريا الشمالية. الرعب
الذي اثاره المجنون في نفوس
بعد على صواريخ كيم ومن الجنوب
الى الشمال. حيث امر زعيم كوريا
يعمل بالوقود الصلب. يبدو ان
سكان كوريا الجنوبية لم يتعودوا
للحزب الشيوعي في الصين وكبير
الدبلوماسيين الصينيين في اول
الصينية وهو الشيء ذاته الذي
اعلن مدير مكتب الشؤون الخارجية
تصريحات له منذ تعيينه حيث قال
ان على بكين والولايات المتحدة
عزمها تطوير ونشر صواريخ
باليستية بعيدة المدى يتراوح
السعي الى الحوار بدلا من
المواجهة. لكن في الجانب
الطاحنة?
وذلك وفق صحيفة الجارديان.
ثلاثمائة وثلاثون مليون دولار
بكين الى استئناف المحادثات
المتوقفة منذ عام الفين وستة عشر
كجيش هتلر? الصين تحتضن اعدائها.
من سياسة الحروب نظرية تسمى
من اجل المحافظة على استقرار
المنطقة. وذلك بالتزامن مع
استمرار العسكرية الصينية بالقرب
من الجزيرة. وقالت اتساي في
يوميا. ايعقل هذا? فلتزوج بها
الشباب المعسرين لينتج لكم جيشا
تأتي ايضا بتحفيز روسيا لجنودها
المنتشرين في اوكرانيا وذلك
القادم لن يكون سهلا مضيفا ان
اعداء روسيا سيحاولون كسرها
الدفاع التركي ان عودة اللاجئين
السوريين يجب ان تكون بشكل طوعي
واخضاعها لكن النصر سيكون حليفها
وفق قوله. الاستعدادات الروسية
النفس الطويل? وهو ان تخضع عدوك
دون قتال. نعم فالحرب ليست كل
نعم خسارة ثقيلة لاغنى رجال
الاعمال الروس بخسارة يومية بلغت
جارتها. لكن كل ذلك لم يمنع
اصدقاء بوتين من دفع ثمن الحرب.
يريد ان يحرق روسيا واضاف ان
الحرب على اوكرانيا هي تجسيد
لرغبة شخص في البقاء على السلطة.
في غضون ذلك قال رئيس مديرية
الشعبية. الاحداث والتطورات.
اثار الملياردير الامريكي غضب
وكالة سبوتنيك فهل يستعد بوتين
لحرب طويلة الامد حقا؟ ليجيب
الاوكراني الى الاستعداد الروسي
كرملين يصرح ان الرئيس الروسي
فكيم لم يحرمهم من شيء فهم
يرقصون نفس هذه الرقصة منذ نصف
قرن تقريبا. ولا يوجد في كوريا
الشمالية سوى هذه الرقصة
مداها بين الفين وثلاثة الاف
كيلومتر وذلك اعتبارا من الفين
عائلة واحدة. ولم يشر الى السعي
لاخضاع الجزيرة تحت السيطرة
والسلطات الكورية تصرح. لا
تستغرب ولا انها تجربة لصاروخ
نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
ديمتري ميدفيديف بقوله ان العام
حتى توالت اصوات الانفجارات
واستمرت على مدار اربع ساعات.
المسيرات برئاسة نائب رئيس
الوزراء. وامر ايضا بانشاء نظام
النطاق مستقبلا على عموم
اوكرانيا. مضيفا ان روسيا يمكنها
الاستخبارات في وزارة الدفاع
الاوكرانية انه لا تزال لدى
الاوكرانيون بليلة رأس السنة.
لكن هذه الاحتفالات تبددت سريعا
الصيني شي جين بينغ من لهجته
تجاه تايبيه في خطابه بمناسبة
انفجار ضخم تردد صداه في سائر
المدينة. وما هي الا دقائق اخرى
مسافات قريبة وبعيدة. المجد
لاوكرانيا المجد للابطال المجد
خطابها الحرب ليست خيارا لحل
المشكلات. فيما غير الرئيس
خمس واربعين طائرة مسيرة روسية
ليلا مع دخول البلاد العام
في التعامل مع زيادة حالات
الاصابة بكوفيد ناينتين كما دعت
البلدان في جميع انحاء العالم
لتقليل اعتمادها على الواردات
الضريبة على الدخل بالاضافة الى
تلقيهم مكافآت وهدايا وذلك في
اطار جهودها الرامية الى حشد
التأييد لعملياتها العسكرية في
لتدريب المتخصصين في تطوير
وانتاج الطائرات المسيرة بحسب
فلاديمير بوتين وجه بانشاء لجنة
حكومية الهدف منها تطوير
بهذا العرض المغري. الصين تقلب
الطاولة على سياسيي العالم وتغير
المواطن ايديهم على صدورهم
بانتظار ردة فعل الزعيم الكوري
بكين وبيونج يانج وكوريا
الجنوبية تستفز المجنون ليضع
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين من
تمويل حربه غير المشروعة وتدعم
سيحتاج الى نحو شهر ونصف لانتاج
صواريخ جديدة. ومن القلق
اوكرانيا وزلنسكي خرج ليقول ان
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
روسيا احتياطيات صاروخية كافية
لشن هجومين او ثلاثة واسعة
ايرانية الصنع بعد منتصف هناك
اعلن سلاح الجو الاوكراني اسقاط
نعم. بوتين شاركهم الاحتفال ولكن
بطريقته الخاصة لتعلن الادارة
العسكرية ان العاصمة استهدفت
بواسطة ثلاث وعشرين طائرة مسيرة
لجارتها اوكرانيا. وقالت وزارة
الخارجية البريطانية انها تحرم
للامة الموت للاعداء. بلادنا فوق
الجميع نعم هكذا احتفل
معروف. فيا لهذا الجنون.
اما في اوكرانيا فكان بعضهم يهتف
على شرفة منزله وعشرات يرددون من
Good. اه هيا بنا لنخنق بوتين.
هكذا اعلنتها بريطانيا بينما
بينما كيم يجعل شعبه يرقص برقصة
موحدة ومن يخالف قوانينها فمصيره
روسيا تشارك الاوكرانيين حفلة
الموت. وبوتين يشحن حماس الجنود
Get out. Everyone's going to
get out. He said get out. Get
out. Get in. Get in.
Caper Shelling is very close.